you're seeing it for the first time i'm
going back to the past
let's go to the old vlog yogi's always
been my favorite because my mother used
to make this homemade
this is where the mob guys were here if
they needed a favor for me they got it
but i didn't want nothing back in return
from them except their love
that's it he was in charge of the
neighborhood frankie
thank you smog
back then you didn't settle things with
guns and knives
those are the moves those are the moves
sneaking away from mom and dad hey
sweetheart yeah but they used to watch
from the window
here mafia used to control this whole
area who controls the block now
[Music]
you cannot erase great memories
with that yeah sports journalists almost
40 years who's this guy in your class
gio gonzalez
you just retired we became buddies i
became his lucky charm
whenever i covered a game with his he
won
we'll go 187 uh and look at the pastry
shop
go up my old block and some of the good
restaurants
we would go to are closed today i forgot
yeah it's monday yeah
oh this is nice some of these uh park
flats are really nice
this is italian right yeah dominick's
dominic's was like uh family style okay
you walk in no menu
what do you want today no bill at the
end uh give me
25 60 cents you're from italy
yeah i'm from naples i'm nepalitan i'm
90 pounds
from two generations back how does it
feel being an italian
coming to the states what are your
thoughts about the us okay guys the
sponsor of today's video is cuts
clothing i like making videos but i hate
shopping
luckily i found the best t-shirt of my
life that works for everything
from walking the streets in the bronx
with rich mancuso to sweltering heat at
the texas border to going out with my
wife for dinner
this shirt does it all the older i get
the more i realize that quality
is important cuts makes products that
last no stretching
worn out collar ironing or pilling i've
used and abused these shirts and they
are indestructible and fantastic for
traveling
yes they cost more than your average
t-shirt but you get what you pay for
with cuts
they also have stylish hoodies and long
sleeve shirts if you want one of the
most durable
slash stylish t-shirts have come across
after
years of searching here's the best one i
found at a discount
to receive 15 off your order click on
the cuts link below in the description
or use the promo code peter at checkout
again that's peter at checkout i
wouldn't recommend something to you that
i didn't fully believe in
or use myself if you want the best
t-shirt of your life
give cuts a try what i say to everybody
you know usa probably is the only
country
in the world that then they still give
it to everybody an opportunity
you know i work like a dog for the last
11 years but you know i gotta do one
restaurant there's a second one
i put in my car i'm close to buy my
house
you know i just something then uh people
in another country
in 10 11 years they never do it you know
if you come in this country and you
wanna
act to it like you actually in naples
you know then uh
two o'clock i say oh i have to go take
my lunch and
have my break you know nap a little bit
no it doesn't work
that's what you stay better you stay
home
why you don't survive over here you can
come
but the sauce is always like homemade
the sauce we made
you know you see
oh there we you know go try to squeeze a
little bit
like this all the flavor coming up when
i was asking my grandma for recipe my
grandma she said you don't need your
italian
gnocchi's always been my favorite
because my mother used to make this
homemade
[Music]
and that's good that's good it's all
about the sauce
yeah my mother made it fresh sunday
morning you woke up to that aroma
right how's this raped this into uh
uh no nothing's better than mom's sauce
it's pretty good sausage
yeah i'd give this a a 10 a 10.
that's huge if the sauce agrees with me
it's good
and those were italians working on that
bridge
sacrificing their lives too a lot of
them sacrificed their lives to build
that was their livelihood and they went
into dangerous territory
to do it underwater above wherever
just
[Music]
we don't get enough credit for what
we've done you're proud
i get emotional with the italians or
what i get emotional because
that's why we kiss why we hug why we
kissed
if i love you a lot if i like you a lot
i'll give you a kiss on a cheek
right
shows our love and gratitude to you
because it's love and lydia your family
you could be my friend that's such a
good friend and i call you family
[Music]
and if you come into my home i will
treat you like family
if you come into town i will treat you
like family
i mean i've got friends that don't live
here no more
all over all the country italian
black latino and i could say they're
like families
[Music]
do you need a wheelchair rich after
those two meals
i'm just tired
[Music]
they do outdoor the dining now on the
weekends
the whole street's closed off right
they're having outdoor dining it's a new
thing
they're keeping this out here yeah it's
a nice thing it's nice
big wave of italians came over 19 the
teens
right like 12 through they came one year
and a lot of these tenements
but it was a big wave before world war
one i believe yeah
yeah yeah this was all far more yeah
jonas bronx he was this uh swedish
exactly yeah and you know the story with
him
and the name how the borough became the
bronx
because you don't do but i forgot you
don't call it the queens of manhattan
the brooklyn statement
because the family was the bronx family
from sweden they bought the they bought
the land from the native americans
yeah and the borough became split from
manhattan
yeah i gotta say in the beginning of our
talk you were saying
neighborhood sliding going downhill
this is pretty nice well no
you know why you're seeing it for the
first time
i'm going back to the past
i'm seeing it the way i grew up with it
right right right
and you're seeing it as a visitors
there's a difference yeah
and generally when people come to the
neighborhood to visit they don't come
here
what they do is go off the revenue to
eat and they go home
let's get a canola or something
you could have it out here if you want
which would the italians they all put
political signs on their doors what's
with that
they've
oh wow
so this this place is what was around
when you were a kid right
different owners
i think same family but cannoli will
always be a cannoli
you're not gonna find a cannoli
different anywhere
unless you leave new york you're all the
same
they're all the same it's basically a
grilled shell
i worked in the old pastry shop down
here with my brothers
i didn't last long because i had
problems i'd always
have more of the cream on me than
putting into the shell
but we all got hired by our two so
pastry shop and that's what we did we
filled the cannoli show they gave us
jobs you know
we're doing a church and we're going to
your your block right yeah we're going
to go to my business the church
that's a lady of mount carmel he might
even be able to walk in there and look
at
inside old
beautiful church my mother and father
got married in there
i got baptized confirmed in there the
whole bit
before we do that homemade
all over the world they come here you
never have a better ravioli than here
they're closed huh yeah
bulgaris gotta come back
here's the old roma cafe i used to sit
here
the roma cafe used to sit inside
outside and have a cappuccino right here
people live to well they still do live
above huh yeah
yeah and here's the old clay street
play street stick it's going to be a
play street stick hole it's closed in
the summer
we'd all come here in the summer and we
could do what we wanted on this street
at summer programs here
olivia moncona beautiful
that's now run by a latino pastor
meeting all
beautiful thank you
yeah i love the architecture in this
church
i don't know how much it is here's a
donation
in here yeah put right
let me do there
what am i doing wrong here
yeah i'm gonna write one more
mother and there we go now what do i do
is it thing yeah just put it in there
right there
no just put it there just put the candle
in
there you go do me a favor yeah yeah
this is to your mother our father
boat that's it
i'll put one in for my father
it's not italian mess no more
people are getting more religious
saturday well this is
you know what because this is uh
latinos are very happy religious
yeah isn't that a beautiful church
beautiful
now when i go in there pete i get
sentimental because that's
where everything happened mother and
father were married there
that can baptize confirms funerals
uh my father's greener was here
in 1993 and he had a block off the
street
because he was fdmi not a cancer it was
very
comfortable they blocked off the whole
block locked this all up because it was
a tremendous turnout for a stream
i delivered the eulogy too like i could
remember what i said
your old place
those are the moves those are the moves
what about you rich you got some of
those moves in here no we used to do the
uh
disco duck we were disco
disco dancers
you weren't dropping those moves now and
it was a pay phone here
that's where you used to make my phone
calls just get out of the house and
a dime a quarter right you right here
was the pay phone right here on this
corner
so you come out here put the diamonds
with the diamonds
who were you calling nice cool
girlfriends i used to call
whatever right here so it was it was
mounted in
yeah it was over here so
rich rich would come out yeah sneaking
away from mom and dad
hey sweetheart yeah but they used to
watch from the window
and i'm gonna show you where that is see
that
building's in great shape now if you
look to the extreme right
uh the right yeah
the next to last floor yeah i see myself
looking out the window where that air
conditioner is
the last second to the end second to the
end to the right
yep okay see that air conditioner yep
that was my old bedroom
and i was on that window all the time my
mother and father's bedroom was next
door
and my mother always used to look out
that window
and dinner time is six o'clock like we
heard earlier
she'd be out that window screaming
nicholas bobby those are my brothers
richard we knew it was dinner time and
you could hear her voice
as far as that way and so when you go to
that phone she could see you from there
oh they knew
i come back in the house who you where'd
you go where'd you get the money from
what are you doing
but you know what we had a guy around
here used to get us
unlimited phone calls on the pay phones
okay
all you had to do was like give him a
tip a dollar two dollars if you had if
you're earning
years ago when i was a kid we used to
have the old ice truck come around
the guy would come around with ice and
sell you ice in a truck
and a little pool truck i come up here
now i get emotional
this is because i look at the windows
that's where you were the second to the
end yeah this side
okay and non-elevated building
so figuring my mother lugging all the
groceries from arthur avenue
up five flights of stairs five or four
flights of stairs she did that almost
four time days a week
and she'd get lost with the traffic with
the people she knew in this neighborhood
building looks good though i see my
mother right now
see your mom
and above me was a neighbor who's a big
met fan older fellow in the family
i'd be out the window he'd be above
he was screaming me did you see what the
mets just did i said yeah andy i just
saw it i
see he was a big met fan so was i as a
kid i was one of the
lone met fans on this block in the
neighborhood
in fact there was a guy that lived up
the block of mr nodal
he's a yankee fan i'm coming home from
school one day
talking mets he's insulting me i got my
car
books with me including the college
thesaurus
and i would try to respond you wouldn't
know because you don't know what this
book is
a thesaurus you know what a thesaurus is
you [ __ ] still just like that because i
went back down
he said no but i want to see it now so
he took the book and he threw it over
this roof
an expensive book yeah right
but my mother saw her from the window
because she was always on that window
she went berserk she went nuts
she screamed you get that book back for
him bubble so what happened was you know
what i said you know what you got bone
stay there i went around the corner
i went to see the mob guys i said i got
a problem
i got a big big big one i got a problem
you sell them up guys i told them
what happened they ran they got him
they took care of him and they told you
go on that roof you get that book
and if it's damaged you're paying cord
for this guy what did he do
he went up that roof got it paid me for
a new one because it was damaged
how do you like that and these walls
here
so you you you put a different view like
you'd have a different look on the mob
than most people of course because they
cared yeah
so most people think criminals
you know if you knew them and they were
good to you
and they knew what i wanted to do and
they saw me with that potential
they were there for me they helped me
they have a clothesline from
the kitchen window to the adjacent
apartment across the way
you'd have to tell the neighbor i'm
hanging up the clothesline you know
and everybody then was tight so no
problem
she'd wash the clothes in the washing
machine the little washing machine and
dry them on the line sometimes the
clothes would fall down the alley and
she would ask me
what my breast can you go down and get
it who lived here
the fantuzi family
italians right from italy
we played stickball here and we played
on the next block
what is stickball exactly you have a
stick and a stick and a spalding
you bought in the store for five cents
okay and you had it that was it
this this is a block here that got
progressively worse over the years
183rd street the school across the
street where i went to public school
ps32
we all went here
and this block just got progressively
worse
so the mob guys would try and control it
they couldn't
wait they the mob couldn't control this
one block oh this whole area
why i think they just didn't want to get
into a war
this is too much of a headache yeah
gotcha
how you doing
[Music]
mafia used to control this whole area
yeah
but those are mainly support yeah
guineas or something like the guinea
pigs
skinnies yeah that was like a
bad word yeah you know but you know what
i was telling him a lot of my friends
were like you know back then
i lived in the neighborhood
[Music]
who who controls the block now or
we do you guys do all right yeah this
was this was
this was always the block to watch this
was beaumont
we used to have rock fights because of
difference now no guns no knives
view rocks against the cam brothers guys
thank you welcome
yeah take care of you guys have a good
one
you know i mean that see calling us
guineas back then was a war
he don't call his guineas but they knew
they knew
what was where skinny or wob both were
the same
not one was he neither one was good but
these buildings have all been renovated
i don't think the young kids know what
the words mean you know but he knew what
guinea was
no but the meaning of the word steve i
would have said yeah we used to call you
spicks
yeah that wouldn't go over well no but
i'm saying the younger generation
doesn't know the meaning of that i was
right yeah i wouldn't call them i
wouldn't
never call a latino
right right right never this is a nice
street here huh yeah
they did nice here this used to be run
down burnt out buildings
yeah it's beautiful there are times that
we want to walk around here because
these buildings work
where is that up here right here right
after this building those those
those houses it was all like you know
burned down
beautiful yeah it was burning i remember
um right here this used to be
a parking lot yeah destroyed it was all
parking i remember these were all burnt
out buildings
yeah i remember you live here there i
used to yeah i'm from here
all right cool i watched this thing
change yeah for the better i grew up
here years ago
way better it's more calm but that block
near the school is always
a rough block right all the time
no because we had the mafia in control
that right there
i heard about all of little italy i
hung out right down here in a club
did the albanians have a mafia uh do you
would you still master shops i wouldn't
be surprised in cigar shops you got to
see them in the cigar shops the way they
sit around the table
you would think they they would it's
like straight out of the movies
take care man thank you thank you thank
you
see you i'm amazed it
you know they know the stories yeah he's
a young guy he knows the story he's a
world renovation this is all new ah
great so it's interesting the albanians
have taken up some of the uh control
of the authority they own property they
own buildings they
huh they're landlords they come from
over there and they come here and where
they
i don't know how they do it but they own
a lot of property
this is where we used to for rocks at
each other the bumps would be on that
side
we'd be on the other that wall was
erected
that's new this was a vacant lot we have
rock fights
and you don't come near us we don't come
near you we end it with rocks
better than guns huh back then you
didn't settle things with
guns and knives the only ones that had
the guns with a mug
we had rocks and fists
and the cops broke it up fast you heard
a siren
you ran you saw a cop you ran
not today what happens when people see
cops now
they don't care this is where the mob
guys were here in here stationed right
here yeah i don't know
what is it now i don't know
let's go so this whole building you can
see the
oh right right right right
the old guys
there we go you know him yeah they put
the race how are you doing
all right i got all the information you
do
you know this guy's still in the club do
they still hang out no they don't they
don't have to scrub no more no more
right because i
grew up in there with them oh did you
who give me some names
and i'll work with you
what about willie mays oh i don't know
what he's doing
right no he's in the nursing home oh
frankie
frankie schmuck he passed
he passed how long ago
frankie must have died about 10 years
ago i'm going to say i've been around
that long
he was good to me i'm living in the
building 32 years
and i worked in the building maybe 10
years before i lived here
so i'm here quite a while so was was the
neighborhood better when these mob guys
were in control
would you say was it safer hard to say
it's hard to know i'm biracial i'm black
and italian
okay i got along sometime i would go
into clubs they would be like oh
am i being filmed yeah is that all right
they
because i was here all the time yeah i
don't think they meant it
because they were good to know but i was
here for years
joe rogers just died in december
he was good to me he sent me to russia
so low
joe sent me to russia he had me run the
boxing gym he opened in the neighborhood
so then you know i ran
ray assault well rapist ray and i used
to go with war all the time
right right ray fought whatever everyone
but i loved him well i don't know
i didn't know frankie died i didn't know
that frankie died a long time ago
i think frankie died he was like 80
years old well he is good to me
there's one guy that still lives here
vinnie
vinnie zika i remember him he still
lives here
is your mom italian are you following
that's my mother's italian so how is
that
growing up in both worlds uh most of the
time i was raised in italian
neighborhoods actually
and you know i'm easy going person so i
blend it in
what's
a brother or something i have two
brothers bob and nick
i remember you you don't remember me i i
got a scooter mask off
wow yeah yeah yeah yeah richie
i think you lived on the third or fourth
floor over there or something and you
had a radio station or something that
was radio there you go
who's right ray was the a trainer old
boxing trainer old school
loudoun big mom mr know it all hated
everybody he loved me and he hated me
and this is what joe i think right here
yeah he was in the horse
and our fiance died a long time ago he's
in the honest game
track with him right here
that's joe this is frankie la casio
right
frank's still in jail right right who i
knew
okay frankie yeah and i knew him too
he was in charge of the neighborhood huh
this guy whoa well he
no brother was but he was he was one of
the family me
uh fortunes right and
again you know his brother was the
second guy down from god right
and second guy from got it and was his
brother
they they respected him they helped
they didn't destroy they weren't bad
they weren't bad people
they kept the neighborhood safe this
neighborhood and so many others
that's what anchorage made what do you
think i mean uh well you speak so highly
of them because
your life was better with them they
helped me
they helped a young guy an italian in
the neighborhood
tiny young guy they helped me they
didn't get me
to where i am what i've done my career i
did that all myself
but they encouraged me they kept me
because anybody in this neighborhood
could have went on the wrong side
and they kept me straight to go stay
stay the right way
they would mentor me they would friend
me
whatever it is if i needed something and
i didn't bother them
or anything because if they loved you
like i told you
they were everything i know you remember
mike nealy yeah
that's the guy i started working with
over here yeah so they gave you
structure
exactly that's the word i didn't need
much because i had a good mother and
father
but out here on the street and they
needed a place to hang out
talk away from my friends it was them
so the it's actually the mob guys that
can keep you out of trouble
okay it's actually what should i call
them the neighborhood guy
actually the neighborhood watch yes uh
nothing bad to say about nothing nothing
i don't know yeah
what people think are you saying that
because you're on camera no
okay i say it in first
i i if i had to kiss their ring
whatever it is i would i wouldn't be
married no but this guy was too humble
to say hey
they like i said wanted to push me in
with to get the
daily news full-time spot but nah i got
to do it
when you were on channel 12 wasn't it i
was yeah
i remember tv i got a good memory
i got a good one it's basically whoever
helps you in life right you want to
well you want to go to a head you want
to be safe if you look at the bronx tale
and this is something that i encourage
you to do that you haven't done yet i
know
you've never seen it you haven't seen it
yet maybe tonight
yeah okay yeah yeah none of it was
filmed no none of it even but they in
the morning
they've a portrayal of the church mont
como was ours it was in brooklyn
or something they did it at the silver
cup studio i don't know where that's
really fun i know it wasn't studios
but if you look at the bronx tale which
is a true story
that explains a lot that's his
neighborhood and
sunny the main guy who was looking after
a young guy
and the father didn't want it just like
my father wanted my father knew all of
them but he didn't
my father did not want me around any of
them because i was the sports guy and
what do you think all these guys were
they're all spokespersons and they loved
me because
they're they're doing betting right yeah
sports betting
and you know everyone knew that but
they loved me because they knew i knew
my sports they knew the talent i had
and if they needed a favor for me they
got it but i didn't want nothing back in
return from them
i never did except their love that's it
just
that's all you need because if i needed
them and i did a few times like i've
told you over the course of the last few
hours
if i needed them and not because i
wanted to do it
they were there for me so the respect
was there
part of la familia which i understand
you cannot erase great memories
and this neighborhood and my italian
roots
you can't erase great memories look at
this am i italian roots too you can't
embrace an enjoyment
one of the best it's one of the best
there'll never be another one like him
nope
i'm going back that way to the bus to
get home all right
we got it two more minutes two minutes
all right
oh charge it for my time all right guys
a little walk down rich's memory lane
well this is beaumont avenue this was
part of it but we're here we're closing
the video we're starting oh
i got two minutes for that you said
you're gonna charge me now
that's only kidding i hope we do this
again yeah that was fun
so guys uh i got a lot out of that i
hope you did too
it's really it's cool to see your your
world
the old world let's call it but also
that restaurant we went into was was new
italians coming in that was interesting
i didn't think that was happening great
it was a good meal and uh
it's new i've never been there before so
and i like what i had i'll go back
so very interesting cultural experience
and i love this neighborhood
i know it's not what it was but come out
to this part of the city
arthur ave like i said it's you can't
erase the great memories
okay that'll never be a raise i'm gonna
be cheesy and say
people should come out here and make new
memories well arthur ave right yeah
yeah they should does it mean i have to
come back and live here in my later
years no
no does it mean i could come back and
visit and always remember
and run into who may be still here yeah
rich
that was awesome my pleasure peter and i
want to leave all of rich's links down
below
he's uh you got a website right uh yeah
coming your social youtube channel is
going up soon richmond because it's
ford's wood ridge
he's got a book coming depending on this
video social media it's facebook rich
vancouver twitter
ring 786 and the numerous websites i
write for i don't have a
website you can look up keep it in the
ring sometimes there's stuff on there
right
i'm writing every day almost every other
day
google my name you'll find me and always
keep it in the ring and keep those
memories alive
all right thanks for coming along guys
we're gonna get out of here before
we hit and uh appreciate it check out
this
check out this neighborhood arthur ave
yep go to the restaurant
literally the bronx breathe in some of
the stories some of the history
exactly until the next one what
what is it by the minute by the hour
and that's uh it was or it is it always
was
closed and opened up again
there's one in every neighborhood